oh that makes me happy
beautiful and scary all right so last
week at a steakhouse in brooklyn an
argument over
women prompted a guy to pull a gun
outside the restaurant
and fire it at his rival but instead he
hit two patrons who were just trying to
enjoy their dinner the suspect who had
five warrants
in north carolina it's almost a band
that's been arrested
and both of the victims are expected to
survive although one of them still has a
bullet lodged in his spine
joining us is dr drew pinsky why is he
joining us because he was at the damn
steakhouse
and he you almost said go ahead
the reason why i want you on dr pinsky
is because i'm so tired of people
telling us that whoa you know this whole
violent epidemic thing
it's like it's just overblown what are
you gonna say now when that happens to
you
oh no it's not overblown and greg greg
discovered i was at peter luger's
because we were sitting next to each
other at cat's
first wedding catching on his tropes
here catching on
uh and he he brought up the peter lucas
shooting i said yeah i was there and he
was like
wasps were there lo and behold we were
there in fact
we were outside uh my wife susan
said why don't we sit outside at this
table we were waiting at and i said you
know i want to go in and get the full
peter luger experience
had we sat at that table we would have
been the object of the bullets
that's incredible i mean that is
actually amazing and they know
luger is a classic restaurant they never
used to have uh
outside seating until of course the
pandemic and so you're kind of like
unprotected out there this guy had a
handgun
he was on i mean the bigger story is why
was this guy
on the street right right well and i
suspect you you guys are like los
angeles right no bail so he's
there again i'm sure yeah uh and so you
know
that's the world we live in right now
and you know it's funny we spend
we love new york spent a lot of time
there but our home is actually los
angeles
and los angeles is such a mess it's just
in you you know you've heard me talk
about that before but this is the first
time i
i came home and felt better in los
angeles right beside the car
around me when i was going through
dangerous areas so when did you
first notice something was wrong i mean
you heard a commotion
uh you were at your table you were the
ocean yeah i was sitting there looking
across towards where the bar is and i
heard a commotion heard someone yell get
call 9-1-1
somebody's down and i saw a woman dive
down behind the cashier counter i
thought oh there's a medical problem
back there i'll go
help so i started heading in that
direction and then the staff came
tearing around the corner and screaming
get down get down gunshots
and uh my wife was already in the corner
she heard the gunshots and she led
everybody there
and the st the staff look peter lugar
staff everyone get your stick at st
peter delivers
they deserve medals they stood tall they
made accounting for everybody they keep
tipped everybody calmed down and i was
astonished
that i was as calm as i was but i think
it was because of those guys yeah you
know i
if i were in this situation i know that
being so important to
america that i need to survive that i
would probably have used my wife as a
shield
to escape and not through the back door
because i'd probably get lost i would
try to go out through the front door
with her as a shield
and she would understand r.i.p um
did you continue eating after this and
i'm just thinking greg you're you're a
different size target than me too and it
might feel safer for you yes uh yes once
we were done because i said you know no
one else in my family was hungry but
i i actually i had strangely had my wits
about me during the whole thing was
trying to keep people safe and things
and when i sat back down at the table i
wanted that peter luger steak and i had
it
you know what you should have ordered
shots for everybody
oh is that a terrible joke you know it
would have been terrible if it was worse
but the thing is
dr drew the this person has i mean when
you have a bullet
that close to your spine this story
could have gone really bad
oh no it's it's a miracle that it wasn't
worse one guy
was shot in the abdomen the other guy
was shot through the back it was almost
a through and through chest wound but
billet the bullet ended up in his spine
i mean
bullets move around this was the whole
thing about the experience was
it was very uncertain we didn't know was
this a drive-by shooting was this a mass
event
was there going to be a shootout with
the cops and by the way kudos to the
brooklyn police
they were there in two minutes had this
been los angeles
we would not even have been speaking to
the 901 operator yet
why were they there so quickly why were
they there so quickly
well apparently they were at an anti-cop
rally just making sure the piece
isn't that amazing they were at an
anti-cop rally
finally the people who hate the police
did something good
they did they did but go ahead
no you do that i'm just it is such an
interesting point that like
oh like there these these cops have to
supervise these
babies at an anti-cop rally and
and actually ironically they have to run
and save people's lives
actually they caught the guy the guy
they they chased the guy down the guy
throwing the gun somewhere
um and now he's i guess him and cat are
dating
[Laughter]
since her five years watching her five
day old wedding imploded
marriage all right dr drew thank you for
coming on
amazing story and i'm glad you're safe
thank you guys and again hats off to the
the weights the waiting staff
by the way how much did you tip a lot
like enough that they came over
afterward and said thank you yeah
all right